PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Hi.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia.
And in this video, we will
see what are hyperparameters,
how to tune them, and set
up a hyperparameter tuning
job in Vertex AI.
All right, so what
is a hyperparameter?
Well, a training application
handles three categories
of data as it trains the model.
The input data, which is
also called training data,
contains the features that the
model uses to make predictions.
Now, but this data
is never directly
part of the model
architecture itself.
The second type of data
is model parameters.
These are the variables that
our ML model or technique
uses to adjust the data.
For example, a deep
neural network, or DNN,
is composed of processing
nodes or neurons,
each with an operation
performed on the data
as it travels
through the network.
Now, when our DNN is
trained, each node
has a weight value that tells
our model how much impact it
has on the final prediction.
Now, they are what distinguishes
our particular model
from other models of the
same architecture trained
on different data.
Now, the third type of
data is hyperparameters.
And these are the
variables that govern
the training process itself.
For example, a part of
designing a deep neural network
is deciding how
many hidden layers
you will want between the
input and the output to be,
and how many nodes each
hidden layer would use.
Like here I have two,
then three, then three,
but this could be
any number of nodes.
These variables are not directly
related to the training data,
and they are the configuration
variables for your model.
Now, when it comes
to model parameters,
they can change with
the training job.
But hyperparameters
are usually going
to stay constant, which means,
in our deep neural network
model example, finding the
right number of hidden layers
means choosing a value of
the number of hidden layers,
training a model, evaluating
it with those values,
and then trying it again
with a different value.
Now, if we wanted to get the
best type of parameter settings
manually, it could get pretty
tedious pretty quickly.
That's where Vertex AI
hyperparameter tuning comes in.
It is an automated process
of tuning hyperparameter jobs
as you're running your
multiple trials of the training
application with values of
the chosen hyperparameters set
within the limits
that you specify.
And to select hyperparameters
that give the best performance,
Vertex AI uses the
Bayesian optimization
for hyperparameter tuning.
If you're interested
in the math behind it,
I've included a link below
to learn more about it.
With that, let's
jump into the console
and train a
hyperparameter tuning job.
Here I am in the
Google Cloud console.
First, you need to enable
Compute Engine and Container
Registry APIs.
In this demo, I'm training and
tuning an image classification
model trained on the
horses or humans data set
from TensorFlow data sets.
We will need a notebook to
containerize our training
application code.
Since I'm creating a TensorFlow
model in this example,
I'm going to select a
TensorFlow Enterprise 2.5
notebook without a GPU.
But you can train a model
built with any framework using
custom or pre-built
containers, so select
the notebook accordingly.
I already created one here,
so let's just hop into that.
In the terminal, I created a
folder called Horses or Humans,
and inside that folder,
I've created a Docker file.
This Docker file uses deep
learning container TensorFlow
Enterprise 2.5 GPU Docker image.
And the deep learning
containers on Google Cloud
actually come with many common
machine learning and data
science frameworks
that are pre-installed.
We're also installing the
Hypertune Library here,
which we will use later
to report the metrics we
want to optimize on Vertex AI.
After downloading the
image, the Docker file
sets up the entry point
for the training code.
Then, I created the Trainer
folder with task.py file
and added the code for
training and tuning the model.
Let's take a deeper
look at this code now.
There are a few components
that are specific to using
hyperparameter tuning service.
The script imports
the Hypertune Library.
We installed this library in the
Docker file we created earlier.
And the function, get_args,
defines a command line argument
for each hyperparameter
that you want to tune.
In this example,
the hyperparameters
that will be tuned
are the learning rate,
the momentum value
in the optimizer,
and the number of neurons in the
last hidden layer of the model.
But feel free to experiment
with others, as well.
The value passed
in these arguments
is then used to set the
corresponding parameters
in the code.
At the end of main function,
the Hypertune Library
is used to define the
metric you want to optimize.
In TensorFlow, declares
model.fit method
returns a history object.
The history.history
attribute is a record
of training loss
values and metrics
values at successive epochs.
If you pass validation
data to model.fit,
the history.history attribute
will include validation loss
and metrics values as well.
If you want the hyperparameter
tuning service to discover
the values that maximize the
model's validation accuracy,
you define the metric
as the last entry,
or NUM_EPOCHS as minus 1
of the val_accuracy list.
Then pass this metric to
an instance of hypertune.
You can pick whatever
string you like
for the hyperparameter
metric tag.
I'm setting it to accuracy here.
But you will need to
use the same string
again later when you kick off
the hyperparameter tuning job.
Now we're ready to
build the container.
Set the project ID, image
URI, build the container
using the image URI.
Once the container
is built, push it
to the container registry.
And then next, let's
head into the Vertex AI
console and create a model to
run our hyperparameter tuning
job.
To configure a training
job, select No Manage Data
Set, Custom Training,
give the model a name,
and then select the custom
container that we just
created from our notebook.
Notice that here, I'm
using Custom Training
via Custom Container on Google
Cloud Container Registry.
But you can also run a
hyperparameter tuning job
with the pre-built containers.
In the next step, enable
hyperparameter tuning,
add learning rate, which would
be double, min and max values,
and log scaling.
Another parameter,
which is momentum,
type would be double,
minimum and maximum values,
linear scaling.
And third
hyperparameter would be
on number of neurons,
discrete type, and of value,
and no scaling for this one.
Next, we need to provide the
metric we want to optimize
as well as the goal.
This should be the same
as our hyperparameter
metric tag we set in the
training application.
It was set to accuracy, and
our goal is to maximize it.
The Vertex AI hyperparameter
tuning service
will run multiple trials
of our training application
with these values.
You will need to put an upper
bound on the number of trials
this service will run.
For demo purposes,
I'm adding 15 here.
More trials generally
lead to better results,
but there will be a point
of diminishing returns
after which
additional trials have
little or no effect
on the metric
you're trying to optimize.
So it's always a best practice
to start with a smaller
number of trials and get
a sense of how impactful
your chosen hyperparameters
are before scaling up
to a larger number of trials.
Now you'll also need to set
an upper bound on the number
of parallel trials.
Here, I'm setting this to three.
Increasing the number
of parallel trials
will reduce the amount of
time the hyperparameter tuning
job takes to actually run.
However, it can reduce the
effectiveness of the job
overall.
This is because the
default tuning strategy
uses results of previous
trials to inform
the assignment of values
in the subsequent trials.
So if you run too many
trials in parallel,
there will be trials that
start without the benefit
of the results from the
trial that are still running.
Now the last step is to
select the search algorithm.
Now grid search is a very
traditional technique
for implementing
hyperparameters.
It's a brute-force, combines
all the combinations.
Now random search randomly
samples the search space
and evaluates the sets
for specified probability
distribution.
For example, instead of trying
to check all the 100,000
samples, we can check 1,000
random sample parameters.
We will select default
search algorithm here,
which will use Google Vizier to
perform Bayesian optimization
for hyperparameter tuning.
To learn more about
how this works,
see the documentation below.
In Compute and Pricing, leave
the selected region as is
and configure Worker Pool
zero with a machine type,
accelerator, and disk size.
Now note here that selecting
GPU is totally optional--
hyperparameter
tuning job will just
take a little longer to complete
if you do not use a GPU.
Then start the training.
It should take about
45 minutes to train
with the demo parameters
that I've selected here.
And when it's
finished, you will be
able to click on the job
name and see the results
of the tuning trials.
From the results
of our trial, we
can see here that setting
the learning rate to 3.9,
momentum to 2.8, and neurons
to 128 results in the highest
validation accuracy.
In this video,
we've learned what
is hyperparameter tuning,
how Vertex AI helps automate
the hyperparameter
tuning process,
and, then, we launched a
hyperparameter tuning job
for training code in Custom
Container via the UI.
If you would like to do the
same using Vertex Python SDK,
I have linked the codelab below.
Give it a try, let me know how
it goes, and for any questions,
reach out to me on
Twitter @pvergadia.